This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例是2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇怪的现代世界中，我将为您剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健康体魄以及培养韧性的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《2%》。数字写作“2”%哦。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年真是疯狂的一年。确实是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你将与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着一套坚硬的盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。艾伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, whenever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. So as you guys know, each week on the podcast, we basically just try and get a bit more sense of this decade that we are living through from untangling, you know, attachment style, dating, dream jobs, figuring out quarter life crises, all of those things.
后果。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨20多岁时经历的重大生活改变与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听众、老听众，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析20多岁的心理学。如大家所知，每周在这个播客中，我们基本上都试图更好地理解我们正在经历的这个十年，从理清诸如依恋风格、约会、理想工作，到弄清楚四分之一人生危机，所有这些事情。
It's all part of like the beautiful, messy business of growing up. But sometimes a topic takes my fancy that is not unique to our 20s, but yet is so fascinating and has so much psychology behind it that I cannot help but do it. And today is one of those topics. We are heading into slightly murky awards today and we're talking about true crime, why we love true crime or this idea of morbid curiosity. True crime podcasts, true crime books, true crime movies and shows, they are one of the leading sources of entertainment. They are a billion dollar industry. People, people love to be exposed to fear and to tragedy and to horror and gore. And it seems so counterintuitive.
这都是成长这段美丽而又纷乱的历程的一部分。但有时我会对某个话题产生兴趣，这个话题虽然不局限于我们的20多岁，但却如此迷人，背后蕴含着如此丰富的心理学原理，以至于我忍不住要深入探讨。今天就是这样一个话题。我们今天要涉足一些稍显阴暗的领域，我们要谈论的是真实犯罪，为什么我们热爱真实犯罪，或者说这种病态好奇心的概念。真实犯罪播客、真实犯罪书籍、真实犯罪电影和节目，它们是主要的娱乐来源之一。这是一个价值数十亿美元的产业。人们，人们喜欢接触恐惧、悲剧、恐怖和血腥。这似乎完全违背直觉。
Why, as humans, as a species that spend so much time pursuing safety and comfort and love? Do we have this kind of darker side of us that is so curious about things that are so tragic and so awful? It turns out that liking true crime doesn't mean that anything is wrong with. with you. In fact, liking true crime is actually quite adaptive. It helps us understand fear. It helps us process danger. It helps us make more sense of a very unpredictable and chaotic world. And on a psychological level, it actually may even provide a some kind of anxiety relief, but be a sense of control that is otherwise really hard to obtain.
为什么作为人类，作为一个花费如此多时间追求安全、舒适和爱的物种？我们内心会有这样一种更黑暗的一面，对如此悲惨和可怕的事情充满好奇？事实证明，喜欢真实犯罪并不意味着你有什么不对劲。事实上，喜欢真实犯罪实际上是非常具有适应性的。它帮助我们理解恐惧。它帮助我们处理危险。它帮助我们更好地理解一个非常不可预测和混乱的世界。在心理层面，它甚至可能提供某种程度的焦虑缓解，但也是一种在其他情况下真的很难获得的掌控感。
It seems very strange, I know, that something so scary could actually provide us with so many benefits and actually leave us feeling positive slash entertained slash relieved. But when you look into the psychology and even the neuroscience of it, it's incredibly fascinating. True crime also, I think, is a very nuanced moral, moral domain and moral area. There's so much humanity in how we handle true crime content. And I think that a lot of us would understand this feeling of becoming quite desensitized to it and feeling like these days you can hear about the worst day of someone's life on TikTok or you can tune in to my favorite murder and listen to the story of someone being brutally killed and that's just
我知道，这听觉起来很奇怪，如此可怕的事情竟然能带给我们这么多好处，甚至让我们感到积极、充满娱乐性或感到宽慰。但当你深入了解它的心理学甚至神经科学时，你会发现它极其迷人。我认为，真实犯罪也是一个非常微妙的道德领域和道德范畴。我们在处理真实犯罪内容时展现出了丰富的人性。我想我们很多人都能理解这种对它变得相当麻木的感觉，觉得现在你可以在TikTok上听到某人一生中最糟糕的一天，或者你可以收听《我最喜欢的谋杀案》，听一个关于某人被残酷杀害的故事，而这只是一种
a normal thing. There's so much true crime content out there. We have to be careful that we continue to have our humanity intact as we consume it and that we continue to understand that these are real people with real families, with real emotions and real pain who have been through this. And their stories are not just for us to listen to or consume on a long car ride. There's also this other area of this whereby when we consume too much, we can actually feel like the world becomes heavier because all we are thinking about and listening to and the information we're giving our brain is that the world is big and scary. So how do we know when we have consumed too much true crime content? How do we know when to stop? And how do we know that this doesn't
很正常的事情。市面上有如此多的真实犯罪内容。我们在消费这些内容时必须小心，确保我们的人性依然完好无损，并且我们继续理解这些都是有血有肉的人，他们有真正的家庭、真实的情感和真正的痛苦，他们经历过这一切。他们的故事不仅仅是供我们在长途车程中收听或消费的。这其中还有另一个领域，那就是当我们消费过多时，我们实际上可能会觉得世界变得更加沉重，因为我们所有的思考、倾听以及输入大脑的信息都在告诉我们，这个世界庞大而可怕。那么，我们如何知道自己何时消费了过多的真实犯罪内容？我们如何知道什么时候该停下来？我们又如何知道这并不会
make us a bad person, even if you feel very drawn to gruesome, awful things? These are all the questions and there's going to be a lot more questions that we're going to answer today, but I really want to dive into this topic of the psychology of morbid curiosity, where the urge comes from to know about crime, how it works, when does it peak, and how does it serve us versus emotionally drain us? This is going to be a very fascinating topic, a little bit unsettling, for sure, but also, I would say, kind of comforting and if nothing else, very, very interesting. So without further ado, let's talk about the psychology behind why we like true crime. Let's start as we always do with the fundamentals, with the basics.
让我们成为一个坏人，即使你对那些毛骨悚然、可怕的事情感到非常着迷？这些都是我们要讨论的问题，今天还将解答更多问题，但我真的很想深入探讨病态好奇心的心理学这一主题，探讨对犯罪的求知欲从何而来，它是如何运作的，它在什么时候达到顶峰，以及它如何服务于我们，还是会消耗我们的情感？这将是一个非常迷人的话题，当然也有些令人不安，但同时，我想说，这也挺抚慰人心的，最不济，也是非常非常有趣的废话少说，让我们来聊聊为什么我们喜欢真实犯罪背后的心理学。让我们像往常一样，从基本原理、基础知识开始。
What is morbid curiosity? Because it is a major precursor to enjoying true crime and horror content. At its core, morbid curiosity is basically the tendency to seek out information or experiences related to dangerous, disturbing, dark or threatening topics. And that could mean death, that could mean violence, that could mean illness, supernatural threats, or even bodily harm. Basically, all the things that scare us and fascinate us in equal measure we feel drawn to. And it sounds really counterintuitive, right? Why would we voluntarily engage with things that scare us, especially when so much of our ordinary life is spent avoiding fear.
什么是病态好奇心？因为它是享受真实犯罪和恐怖内容的一个主要前置条件。在其核心，病态好奇心基本上是一种寻找与危险、令人不安、黑暗或威胁性主题相关的信息或经历的倾向。这可能意味着死亡，可能意味着暴力，可能意味着疾病、超自然威胁，甚至身体伤害。基本上，所有那些以同等程度吓唬我们和吸引我们、让我们感到被其吸引的事物。这听起来真的很反直觉，对吧？为什么我们会自愿接触那些让我们感到害怕的事物，尤其是当我们的日常生活中大部分时间都在避免恐惧时。
Researchers actually say that we are driven to be curious about morbid events because, as humans, we have this inbuilt need to explore novel stimulating things that excite us in some way. And if you're thinking, excited might not be the right word here. It is worth noting that feeling excited isn't just something that happens in response to positive experiences. excitement actually is just activation of extreme interest. So it can be in response to negative and alarming events as well as cheerful or positive ones.
研究人员实际上表示，我们被驱动去对病态事件感到好奇，是因为作为人类，我们有一种与生俱来的需求，去探索新奇的、能以某种方式激起我们兴奋的刺激性事物。如果你在想，“兴奋”这个词在这里可能不太合适。值得指出的是，感到兴奋不仅仅是对积极体验的一种反应。兴奋实际上只是对极端兴趣的激活。因此，它既可以是对消极和惊人事件的反应，也可以是对愉快或积极事件的反应。
So to understand this further, you need to know this name. Dr. Colton Scrivener. He is a leading researcher at Arizona State University and he primarily focuses on true crime fascination and the psychology behind it. He actually developed something very useful in this conversation called the morbid curiosity scale. So he wanted to know, okay, some people like this kind of dark content, some people like this. What are the different categories of dark horror, crime content that people like and what kind of person feels drawn to each of them? So he broke it down into four main categories. Dangerous animals, shark attacks, poisonous snakes, that kind of.
为了进一步理解这一点，你需要知道这个名字。柯尔顿·斯克里夫纳博士。他是亚利桑那州立大学的一名顶尖研究人员，主要研究真实犯罪的痴迷及其背后的心理学。他实际上在这个对话中开发了一个非常实用的工具，叫做病态好奇心量表。所以他想知道，好吧，有些人喜欢这种黑暗的内容，有些人喜欢那种。人们喜欢的黑暗恐怖、犯罪内容有哪些不同的类别，什么样的人会受吸引去接触其中每一种？于是他将其分为四大类。危险动物，鲨鱼袭击，毒蛇，诸如此类。
thing. People who like violent interpersonal events, so crime, murder, assault, criminal psychology, true crime series fans, that's the one they, that's the category they fall into. Next, supernatural threats. So people who like ghosts, demons, the occult, paranormal activity films, those kind of things. And finally, bodily violations. So autopsies, medical anomalies, graphic injuries, car crashes. Not everyone's morbid curiosity is the same. I personally hate supernatural movies. I will not watch one. But I love podcasts and documentaries about animal attacks.
类。喜欢暴力人际事件的人，如犯罪、谋杀、袭击、犯罪心理学，真实犯罪系列剧的粉丝，这就是他们所属的类别。接下来，超自然威胁。喜欢鬼魂、恶魔、神秘学、超自然现象电影的人，诸如此类。最后，身体违背。如尸检、医学异常、严重受伤、车祸。并非所有人的病态好奇心都是一样的。我个人讨厌超自然电影。我绝对不会看。但我喜欢关于动物袭击的播客和纪录片。
Specifically, this one called tooth and claw. Like it has been the top of my Spotify wrapped every single year. I'm fascinated by it. You, on the other hand, might get super creeped out by that and just not even interested in it at all. but really love medical shows or really love, you know, really graphic pimple-popping videos. The way that we experience excitement and thrill from different morbid events is going to differ between each of us. And some people might not even have it at all. Different types of morbid curiosity, though, those different categories seem to correlate with different psychological traits.
具体来说，有一个叫“牙齿与利爪”的节目。它甚至每年都排在我Spotify年度回顾的榜首。我对它着迷不已。而你，另一方面，可能会被那个吓得毛骨悚然，甚至根本不感兴趣。但你可能真的很喜欢医学节目，或者真的很喜欢那些非常血腥的挤黑头视频。我们从不同的病态事件中体验到兴奋和刺激的方式因人而异。有些人甚至可能根本没有这种体验。不过，不同类型的病态好奇心，那些不同的类别，似乎与不同的心理特征相关联。
So people high in openness to experience, for example, they are more likely to enjoy complex, thought-provoking forms of true crime documentaries or dark philosophical fiction. In this way, I think it's because they have a real interest in what drives humans to do certain things. There's a real intellectual curiosity there. But people with different personalities, particularly people who are quite kinesthetic and really understand and learn through their bodies and through movement, they tend to be more fascinated by bodily violations. So it is actually quite individual. People who are really like sensation-seeking and are risk-takers, they are more likely to enjoy graphic horror, intense gore, very thrill-heavy
例如，在开放性体验上得分较高的人，他们更有可能欣赏复杂、引人深思的真实犯罪纪录片或黑暗的哲学小说。从这个意义上说，我认为这是因为他们对驱使人类做出某些行为的动机有着真正的兴趣。这里面存在着一种真正的智力好奇心。但有着不同个性的人，特别是那些非常具动觉型、真正通过身体和运动来理解和学习的人，往往对身体违背现象更加入迷。所以这其实因人而异。那些真正喜欢寻求刺激和冒险的人，更有可能享受血腥恐怖、极度残忍、充满惊悚悬疑的
mysteries. You can see that it really comes back to our individual preferences and our character. But back to that main question, why? It turns out that personality has a lot to do with what kind of morbid content you like, but also why you like it. So linking back to that researcher we talked about before, he found that there are certain things that people who like morbid content have in common. So yes, they might be driven to different forms of darkness, but they often rate or rank quite high in terms of rebellious nonconformity. So they like to push boundaries. They like to challenge norms. They're also often quite curious, very socially curious, very intellectually curious. And so they are attracted to things that aren't typically discussed, that might be a little bit taboo, that also
谜团。你可以看出，这确实归结为我们的个人偏好和性格。但回到那个核心问题，为什么？事实证明，性格不仅与你喜欢哪种病态内容有很大关系，还与你为什么喜欢它有很大关系。回到我们之前谈到的那位研究人员，他发现喜欢病态内容的人有一些共同点。所以，是的，他们可能会被不同形式的黑暗面所吸引，但他们在叛逆的非顺从性方面通常得分或排名相当高。所以他们喜欢突破界限。他们喜欢挑战规范。他们通常也充满好奇心，在社交和智力上都极具好奇心。因此，他们会被那些通常不被讨论、可能有点禁忌、同时也因为其极其复杂而引人入胜的事物所吸引。
are very fascinating because of how complex they are. You know, this idea of why do humans hurt other humans, it's not something that has a simple answer. Every case is going to be different. Every person's motivations are going to be influenced by different experiences and different things. And so people who are quite socially curious see the minds of these individuals as a challenge. Another really compelling explanation comes from evolutionary psychology. So from an evolutionary perspective, morbid curiosity likely developed as a way to help us now. navigate and survive in a very dangerous world. You've got to remember these things exist for a reason. You know, if morbid curiosity didn't have a purpose, it wouldn't be as common as it is.
你知道，关于人类为什么要伤害其他人类这个概念，并没有简单的答案。每个案件都不同。每个人的动机都会受到不同经历和不同事物的驱动。因此，那些社交好奇心强的人会将这些个体的心理视为一种挑战。另一个非常令人信服的解释来自进化心理学。从进化的角度来看，病态好奇心的发展很可能是为了帮助我们如今在危机四伏的世界中进行导航和生存。你必须记住，这些事情的存在是有原因的。你知道，如果病态好奇心没有目的，它就不会像现在这样普遍。
But in early human history, being able to learn from threats without having to directly experience them would have been incredibly beneficial. You know, if you watched someone else eat a poison, despair, you knew to avoid it. If you heard a story about a deadly predator lurking nearby, you knew to steer clear of that area. Our ancestors would simulate those threats in their minds as a way to develop survival strategies. It's basically a primitive version of high-stakes observational learning. So nowadays, we do that through consuming certain forms of entertainment. And this is where the concept of threat simulation comes in.
但在人类早期历史中，能够在不必直接经历威胁的情况下从中学习，将是极其有益的。你知道，如果你看着别人吃下某种毒药而死去，你就知道要避开它。如果你听到关于附近潜伏着致命掠夺者的故事，你就知道要远离那个地区。我们的祖先会在脑海中模拟这些威胁，以此来制定生存策略。这基本上是高风险观察学习的原始版本。所以现在，我们通过消费特定形式的娱乐来做到这一点。这就是威胁模拟概念发挥作用的地方。
Morbid curiosity serves as a kind of threat learning system. We're drawn to frightening and graphic content because on a psychological level, our brain wants to gather information about how to survive. So that would have been really adaptive previously for helping us to understand threats from a safe distance. Nowadays, we really seek out knowledge and danger about the current human condition, not because we enjoy suffering, but because we want to understand it more so that we are more prepared. And that kind of feels comforting and provides a little bit of relationship. there is some further value to consuming this content as well. And it was really revealed during
病态好奇心充当了一种威胁学习系统。我们之所以被可怕和血腥的内容所吸引，是因为在心理层面上，大脑想要收集关于如何生存的信息。因此，这在以前对于帮助我们从安全距离理解威胁具有极高的适应价值。如今，我们真正寻求的是关于当前人类状况的知识和危险，不是因为我们喜欢受苦，而是因为我们想要更多地理解它，以便做好更充分的准备。这感觉有些许安慰，并提供了一种联系。
COVID, during the pandemic. These researchers were looking at who was doing better, who was coping with what was a very scary time, who was coping with all the loss and also all the uncertainty and all the fear. And they found that it was people who scored higher on the morbid curiosity scale. So they liked horror, they liked true crime, who were more psychologically resilient. Why was this the case? Well, because they had already rehearsed their approach to fear and danger. They were familiar with crisis narratives. In that sense, their curiosity about these things beforehand had almost mentally prepared them for the unknown. Like they had most likely simulated and been exposed to crises over and over again in their mind. And so that gave them a
消费这些内容其实还有更深层的价值。这一点在疫情期间表现得尤为明显。当时研究人员正在观察谁过得更好，谁能应对那个非常可怕的时期，谁能应对所有的损失、不确定性以及恐惧。他们发现，在病态好奇心量表上得分更高的人——也就是说他们喜欢恐怖片、喜欢真实犯罪——在心理上更具韧性。为什么会这样呢？因为他们已经排练过面对恐惧和危险的方法。他们对危机叙事很熟悉。从这个意义上说，他们之前对这些事情的好奇心几乎在精神上为他们面对未知做好了准备。就像他们很可能在脑海中一次又一次地模拟并接触过危机一样。因此，当真正的恐惧来临时，这赋予了他们一个可以调用的心理工具包，在某种程度上对它产生了免疫力。你知道，你接种疫苗，疫苗起作用的原因是它让你接触少量无害的病毒，这样当你真正遇到它时，你就能受到保护。这些人一直用可怕的内容给自己接种疫苗，几乎建立了一种免疫力。
psychological toolkit to draw from when real fear kind of arrived, kind of being inoculated against it in a way. You know, you get a vaccine and the reason a vaccine works is because it exposes you to a small amount of the virus that is not harmful and then you're protected when you do encounter it. These individuals had been inoculating themselves with scary content, building up like this almost immunity. This kind of threat learning, it's not that something is wrong with you. actually very adaptive. This is what this is saying. It's an emotional armor for a very chaotic world. And there's also some fascinating neuroscience behind this as well. If you dip into the brain of someone who is consuming, let's say, a serial killer podcast or watching criminal minds,
这种威胁学习，并不是说你有什么不对劲。实际上它非常具有适应性。这就是这段话所表达的意义。它是面对极其混乱的世界的一种情感盔甲。这背后也有一些迷人的神经科学原理。如果你去观察一个正在收听连环杀手播客或观看《犯罪心理》的人的大脑，
what you will see is several regions lighting up. The first one is the amygdor, which is our brain's fear center. It becomes active. Of course, this part of the brain becomes active because it's responsible for detecting threats and initiating, you know, your fight or flight response. But we also see the activation of this part of the brain called the insular. And this is a region involved in processing empathy. So it can also be quite a human experience. But the fascinating part that they also would see is that although these brain regions were lighting up, in general, other parts of the brain were also quite active.
你会发现有几个区域被点亮了。第一个是杏仁核，这是我们大脑的恐惧中心。它变得活跃。当然，大脑的这一部分变得活跃，是因为它负责检测威胁并启动你的战斗或逃跑反应。但我们还会看到大脑中被称为岛叶的区域被激活。这是一个参与处理共情（同理心）的区域。因此，这也可以是一种非常人性化的体验。但他们还会看到一个迷人的现象是，尽管这些大脑区域被点亮了，但总的来说，大脑的其他部分也相当活跃。
So we actually felt quite safe. These individuals had this danger response, but it wasn't overriding other responses in their brain. It was almost borrowing the intensity of these experiences that they were watching on screen or that they were listening to for entertainment and almost is like a training ritual for our brain, right? It's like you go to the gym to stretch a brain. muscle, they were watching this true crime content and it was like their brain was practicing
所以我们实际上感觉相当安全。这些个体确实有这种危险反应，但它并没有凌驾于大脑中的其他反应之上。它几乎是借用了他们在屏幕上观看或作为娱乐收听的这些体验的强度，几乎就像是我们大脑的训练仪式，对吧？就像你去健身房是为了拉伸大脑肌肉一样，他们在观看这些真实犯罪内容时，就像是大脑在练习
its fear response whilst also not shutting down the rest of the body. It's a gym for our emotions. And a 2013 study at the University of Amsterdam, it did find that horror movies, true crime, they do trigger arousal. They do get our heart rate going. They make us tense. There's faster breathing. But this alarm reaction is actually mimicking, mimicking. actual danger. In some part of our brain knows that we're okay. It knows that we're physically safe. You'll still get the adrenaline. You'll still get the thrill. But there was also this weird sense of satisfaction, walking away, feeling that you have conquered the fear. And that is what kept people coming back to this form of content. It was giving us a safe way to experience
它的恐惧反应，同时又没有关闭身体的其他部分。这是我们情绪的健身房。阿姆斯特丹大学2013年的一项研究确实发现，恐怖电影、真实犯罪确实会引发唤醒。它们确实会让我们的心率加快。它们让我们紧张，呼吸会变快。但这种警觉反应实际上是在模仿真实的危险。我们大脑的某个部分知道我们是安全的。它知道我们在物理上是安全的。你仍然会感受到肾上腺素飙升。你仍然会感受到刺激。但离开时也会有一种奇怪的满足感，觉得你已经征服了恐惧。正是这一点让人们不断回头观看这种形式的内容。它为我们提供了一种安全的方式去体验
unsafe things, tricking us into thinking that we've done something brave, but these people never actually left the room. They never actually went outdoors. There's actually been some research into this being quite good for people with anxiety. You know, morbid curiosity offers the strange but meaningful form of comfort. And some of you even reached out to me and said this. When I posted that I was going to do this episode, one of you DM'd me and said, I have such intense anxiety, but I love true crime content. I love learning about danger because it makes it feel knowable. It like shrinks its power.
不安全的事情，哄骗我们觉得自己做了勇敢的事，但这些人实际上从未离开房间。他们实际上从未走到户外。实际上有一些研究表明这对于焦虑症患者相当有益。你知道，病态好奇心提供了一种奇怪但意义重大的安慰形式。你们中的一些人甚至联系我并告诉了我这一点。当我发布我要做这期节目时，你们中的一个私信我说：“我有这么严重的焦虑，但我喜欢真实犯罪内容。我喜欢了解危险，因为它让危险变得可以理解。它削弱了它的力量。”
And, you know, that's actually quite a revealing thing, right? It's this sense that if you understand the monster, maybe you can survive it. If you've read the story, you can rewrite the ending. And so watching true crime almost in a way, is providing people with a sense of pseudo-control that in a very chaotic world we typically don't actually get. Let's talk about how gender plays into this as well, because something that may or may not surprise you is that women consume true crime content at a much higher frequency than men. We're all over it. In some cases, it's been estimated that around 80% of the audience for true crime
你知道，这其实是一件挺有启示意义的事情，对吧？这种感觉是，如果你理解了怪物，也许你就能在它手下生还。如果你读过这个故事，你就能重写结局。因此，观看真实犯罪几乎在某种程度上为人们提供了一种伪控制感，这种控制感在一个极其混乱的世界中，我们通常是很难真正得到的。让我们也来谈谈性别是如何影响这一点的，因为有一件事可能会或可能不会让你感到惊讶，那就是女性消费真实犯罪内容的频率远高于男性。我们对此无处不在。在某些情况下，据估计，真实犯罪观众中大约80%
is women. I know personally as a woman, I constantly hear about gender-based. crimes and I'm constantly thinking about my safety in a way that I know my boyfriend and my male friends and my dad and my cousins do not. And I don't know about some of you, but I find myself consuming a lot of true crime content where the victims are women. Obviously because crimes against women are so high and the rates are so much higher, but also because when I hear stories about women, I immediately pay attention and I feel instinctually more drawn in. And that's not a coincidence. Research has really found and shown time and time again. Men are really interested in supernatural horror and aggressive content. Women are drawn to true crime, serial killers,
是女性。我作为女性深有体会，我经常听到基于性别的犯罪，我经常在思考自己的安全问题，而我知道我的男朋友、我的男性朋友、我的爸爸和表弟们是不会这样想的。我不知道你们当中是否有人和我一样，发现自己正在消费大量受害者是女性的真实犯罪内容。显然是因为针对女性的犯罪率如此之高，且比率高得多，而且还因为当我听到关于女性的故事时，我会立刻集中注意力，本能地感到更加被吸引。这并非巧合。研究一次又一次地发现并表明。男性对超自然恐怖和攻击性内容真的很感兴趣。女性则被真实犯罪、连环杀手
and murder. Because their interest is stemming not just from curiosity, but also from kind of a survival learning mechanism place. Our interest in true crime is really stemming from the fact that these narratives speak to real gender-based threats that women are more statistically likely to face. And in this way, morbid curiosity often reflects real-world hypervigilance. For women, stories about danger can feel really personal. And so we want to understand what happened. We want to understand how it happened. We want to know what the signs were in hindsight, because consciously or not, we are trying to protect ourselves. True crime, yes. on the surface looks like entertainment, it's actually more about risk assessment. It's not just
和谋杀所吸引。因为她们的兴趣不仅源于好奇心，还源于某种生存学习机制。我们对真实犯罪的兴趣确实源于这样一个事实，即这些叙事触及了女性从统计数据来看更有可能面临的真实基于性别的威胁。通过这种方式，病态好奇心往往反映了现实世界的过度警惕。对女性而言，关于危险的故事会让人感觉非常个人化。所以我们想了解发生了什么。我们想了解它是如何发生的。我们想知道事后看来有哪些征兆，因为无论是有意识还是无意识，我们都在试图保护自己。真实犯罪，是的。表面上看起来像娱乐，但实际上更多的是风险评估。这不仅仅是
why did he do it. It's how can I avoid this happening to me. Again, linking in to the fact that true crime might be a proxy for a greater sense of control and for a greater sense of preparedness, I guess. Of course, there is also a fine line between curiosity, preparedness and exploitation. You know, when it is done respectfully and when true crime is considerate of any victims involved, these experiences can offer really powerful opportunities for reflection and education. The tricky part is when they begin to become sensationalized or commercialized. We need to become cautious of when the suffering of real people becomes entertainment, because when this happens, we risk turning empathy into a real spectacle. I had an
为什么他要这么做。而是我该如何避免这种情况发生在我身上。再次联系到这样一个事实，即真实犯罪可能是对更大掌控感和更高防范意识的一种替代品，我想是的。当然，在好奇心、防范准备和剥削之间也存在着一条微妙的界限。你知道，当处理方式得体且真实犯罪考虑到所涉及的任何受害者时，这些经历可以提供非常强大的反思和教育机会。棘手的部分在于它们开始变得耸人听闻或商业化时。我们需要警惕，当真实之人的苦难沦为娱乐时，因为当这种情况发生时，我们就有把同理心变成一场真正的奇观的风险。几年前我在播客上邀请过一位
amazing woman on the podcast a few years back, talk about navigating extreme trauma. And her name was Amy. And her mother was really tragically murdered by her brother. And then that same brother tried to organize for her to be murdered by fellow inmates who were about to get out whilst he was still in prison. And that was her real life. That was her daily experience of fear and grief and lost and she was so open in sharing about what true crime content meant to her and how there is a very fine line between talking about true crime for the purposes of awareness, solving cold cases, and then just for entertainment. And what she said to me was there are a couple ways to really tell whether what you're consuming is good or bad. Firstly, does the podcast or show talk about the
了不起的女性，谈论她如何应对极端创伤。她的名字叫艾米。她的母亲不幸被她的亲哥哥谋杀。然后那个亲哥哥甚至还在监狱里试图策划让即将出狱的狱友来谋杀她。这就是她的现实生活。那是她每天都在经历的恐惧、悲伤和失去，她非常坦诚地分享了真实犯罪内容对她意味着什么，以及为了提高意识、侦破悬案而谈论真实犯罪，与纯粹为了娱乐而谈论真实犯罪之间，存在着一条非常微妙的界限。她对我说，有几种方法可以真正辨别你所消费的内容是好是坏。首先，这个播客或节目是否谈论了
families? Does it contain their permission to talk about the case? Do they bring the family on? Do they victim blame or do they solely blame the perpetrator, the person who is responsible? Do they bring attention to cold cases or just to cases where there's been a big trial or there's been some big jury finding or, you know, a big splashy front page news cover? Do they donate to gendered violence charities. Yes or no? Do they make jokes about the experiences or are they really just focused on the facts and the truth? These are important questions to ask if you want to keep listening, if you want to keep watching, if you want to keep reading about true crime in a way that preserves your humanity because I don't think it's bad to want to know. It's actually profoundly human as
受害者家属？它是否获得了谈论该案件的许可？他们是否邀请了家属上节目？他们是在责备受害者，还是仅仅责备肇事者、那个应当负责的人？他们是将注意力吸引到悬案上，还是仅仅吸引到那些有过盛大审判、有过重大陪审团裁决、或者是登上头版头条的案件上？他们是否向性别暴力慈善机构捐款？是还是不是？他们是拿这些经历开玩笑，还是真正专注于事实和真相？如果你想继续收听、继续观看、继续以一种保持你人性尊严的方式阅读真实犯罪，这些都是需要问的重要问题，因为我不认为想要了解情况是一件坏事。正如我们所讨论的，这实际上是极其深刻的人性表现，但同时，只有当它包含同情心和同理心时，才能真正体现深刻的人性。因为如果你消费这些内容只是为了说，“哦，希望这不要发生在我身上”，或者“哦，好吧，这挺有趣的，我很无聊，我需要寻求刺激”。我认为这不是对待他人生命或他人也许经历的应有善良方式。好了，我们要稍作休息，但当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么我们的病态好奇心通常会在20多岁时达到顶峰，以及你如何在现有的海量内容中找到某种平衡。
we've discussed, but also can only be profoundly human if it contains compassion and empathy. Because if you are just consuming to be like, oh, I hope this doesn't happen to me, or, oh, well, that's interesting and I'm bored and I need a thrill. I don't think that's a kind way to treat what is someone else's life and someone else's perhaps. Okay, we are going to take a short break, but when we return, we're going to explore actually why our morbid curiosity typically peaks in our 20s and also how you can find some balance with the amount of content out there.
所以请继续收听。2%。当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例是2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。在这个奇怪的现代世界中，我将剖析坚韧不拔的意志、健康体魄以及培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？我们弄错了。
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是T-W-O-Persent。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的这个新季节里……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己在这里被卡车撞了。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit here. by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
我心想，这怎么会发生在我身上。警察似乎并不在意。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道。
what you're thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark
你在想什么，乔治·布什跟莉儿·金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。
Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。那么，让我们来关注一下根据研究，为什么真实犯罪和恐怖内容的消费实际上在我们的20多岁时达到顶峰。我整个星期都在思考这个问题，因为直到我开始真正为这期节目做研究之前，我根本不知道会有这种情况。然后我发现了所有这些迷人的统计数据，它们基本上表明，真实犯罪的最大受众是，是的，各个年龄段的女性，但20多岁的人大概构成了第二大群体。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So let's zoom in on why true crime and hard. consumption actually peaks in our 20s, according to research. I have been thinking about this all week because I had no idea that this was the case until I started to really research this episode. And then I found all these fascinating statistics that basically said that the biggest audience for true crime is, yes, women of all ages, but people in their 20s make up probably like one of the second biggest groups.
我认为在这个十年里，我们之所以如此被这类东西吸引，是因为在这个时期存在着很多的不安定因素。有很多存在主义的问题。有新的独立。对我们中的许多人来说，这是我们第一次真正意识到自己的死亡，不是以抽象的意义，而是以一种真实、具体的方式。这是充满许多“第一次”的十年，也是我们第一次面对许多存在主义问题的十年。
I think the reason why in this decade we are so drawn to this kind of stuff is because there is a lot of instability during this period. There are a lot of existential questions. There's new independence. For many of us, it's the first time we truly become aware of our own mortality and not in an abstract sense, but in a real tangible way. This is the decade of a lot of firsts and the first time we face a lot of existential questions.
我们搬出去住。我们失去了亲人。我们近距离看到不公正，我们获得了独立但也带来了焦虑。突然之间，死亡、危险或悲伤的概念不再只是理论上的了。它是真实的。随之而来的问题是，直面最糟糕的情况到底意味着什么？当它发生时我有能力应对吗？病态好奇心成为了一种无需亲身经历就能直面这些问题的方式。
We move out. We lose loved ones. we see injustice up close, we gain independence but also anxiety. And suddenly the idea of death or danger or grief, it isn't just theoretical. It's real. And with all of that comes the question, what does it really mean to just face the worst? And am I going to be capable when it happens? Morbid curiosity becomes a way to confront these questions without having to live them.
你知道，通过观看、倾听、阅读、想象，我们测试不同的情境。你知道，如果我在那种情况下会怎么样？我会做何反应？我会如何生存？我会作何感受？在我们的20多岁，也有一种深入了解世界如何运作的深切需求。而病态好奇心正是其中的一部分。它帮助我们了解最坏情况，这样我们或许可以预防它们，或者至少
you know, by watching, listening, reading, imagining, we test out different scenarios. You know, what if I was in that situation? How would I react? How would I survive? How would I feel? There's also a deep need in our 20s to figure out how the world works. And morbid curiosity is part of that. It helps us learn about the worst case scenarios so that maybe we can prevent them or at least
理解它们。这其实也是一种建立联系的体验。这其中也有社交的一面，你知道，分享恐怖故事、对真实犯罪的痴迷、深夜在TikTok上刷视频无法自拔。这可以是一种非常棒的凝聚体验。承认我们对这些黑暗事物感到害怕或着迷，然后听到另一个人说“是的，我也对此着迷，让我们一起来探讨吧”，这本身就是一种脆弱性的展现。你知道，这正是能把人们联系在一起、让我们着迷、并且我认为能将我们作为一个人类物种凝聚在一起的事情，就像是在说：“哇，你也感受到了这种复杂的情感吗？我也是。”还有一件事需要考虑。我认为
understand them. And it's kind of a bonding experience. There is a social side to this as well, you know, sharing scary stories, true crime obsessions, late night TikTok rabbit holes. It can be such a bonding experience. And there is the kind of vulnerability in admitting that we're scared or fascinated by this dark stuff and then hearing someone else say, yeah, I also am fascinated by that. And let's talk about it together. You know, it's just something that, bonds people and that fascinates us and that I think brings us together as this human species of like, wow, do you feel this complex emotion? I do too. Here's something else to consider. I think
理解它们。这其实也是一种建立联系的体验。这其中也有社交的一面，你知道的，分享恐怖故事、对真实犯罪的痴迷、深夜刷TikTok无法自拔。这真是一种很好的建立联系的方式。而且，承认我们害怕或是对这些黑暗的东西着迷，本身就有一种脆弱感，然后听到别人说，是的，我也对那个很着迷，让我们一起来聊聊吧。你知道的，这正是那种能把人们联系在一起的事物，它让我们着迷，并且我认为它将我们人类这个物种凝聚在了一起，就像是在说，哇，你也有这种复杂的感情吗？我也有。还有一件事需要考虑，我认为
morbid curiosity isn't just about fear. It's also about identity. And in our 20s, when we're constantly trying to figure out who we are, sometimes these examples of, you know, people being murdered, people being killed, these terrible things gets us to really ask the question of like, what would I, like, what do I value? What do I want in my life? How do I relate to the world? What do I see as justice? What do I see as revenge? What do I see? What do I want? And there's just all these big questions and it's incredibly rich and you really end up acknowledging a lot more about yourself and how you see the world, then you think. And I know you're probably listening to this thing, like, are we talking about the same thing? Like, true, I just listen to true crime because
I'm bored at work. Yes, but there's actually more to it than that. Let's now talk about another essential part of this that we've kind of been milling around for a little bit, which is, where's the boundary? How do we know what disturbs us too much? How do we know when we've gone too far. It's something I have definitely experienced. Being exposed to so much tragic, awful stuff, it actually can create a lot of vicarious stress and vicarious trauma. This was my experience during my true crime phase. You know, I actually felt like my life was becoming more dangerous and more scary. I became more suspicious. I became more hypervigilant, even though none of these things were actually happening to me. But it did make me apprehensive. It made me anxious. It made me feel heavy.
And you have to remember, you know, you are what you expose your mind to. You and your brain have a two-way relationship and the information and the content that you feed it matters. It influences our mood, our mindset, our stress levels, our outlook on life. And so, If you are going to work and every single day you are putting your headphones on and listening to how Joe murdered Sally and how Igor chopped up seven people, that is the lens through which you are going to see the world. You're going to see the world as dark. Humanity is cruel.
People are mean. Violence is normal. When we start doom scrolling and compulsively watching violent content, you might also have the opposite reaction of feeling very numb to tragedy and entirely desensit. When that happens, what you're experiencing is something called compassion fatigue. And this term was originally coined by a psychologist called Charles Figley. And he was actually using it to describe the emotional exhaustion experience by care workers and people who work with trauma victims. So therapists, nurses, aid workers. And he was seeing this thing where, you know, people
would come in and they would be, they would not have any limbs and they would have been through these terrible things and the nurses would be like impatient with them almost and like not affected by it at all and this is how he essentially realized that when you were exposed to too much terrible stuff your compassion can actually run out and obviously watching a horror film is not equivalent to being a frontline you know care worker but i do think it's important to recognize the impact of how readily available horrific media is to us now because we have a smartphone phones because of the algorithms, we are constantly exposed to other people's pain, to TikToks and news reports and Instagram videos of just some of the worst things happening in the world right now.
And if you pick up your phone first thing in the morning, that's the first thing your brain is seeing. Compassion fatigue is really not something that we want to mess with because it is very, very difficult to get out of. It is very difficult to break free from, much like burnout. Now, compassion is such a human part of us. And when it's switched off, it means that something like really significant has kind of switched in our brain. It means that there has been an extreme trauma or it means that we've kind of, I don't want to say lost a part of our humanity,
but definitely the empathy centers in our mind have not been working properly for a little, for a little while. There is only so much pain that you can absorb as well. Like, it's not like you have gone in there and switched your brain off. It's not like it's your fault. Is your brain trying to protect you and saying, okay, we need to preserve a sense of safety and a sense of justice and a sense of fairness and a sense of kindness and comfort. And this content isn't helping us. So we need to switch off our reaction to it entirely to preserve, you know, this equilibrium, this emotional equilibrium of safety. And that's the paradox, right? We, we, we, we consume this content to feel more informed, but if we're not careful, it can end up making
us feel helpless or actually making us be completely closed off to any lessons. So here's the question you need to ask yourself. After you consume this kind of content, do you feel more curious and connected or do you feel more anxious, numb or fatigued? After consuming this content, Do you feel fearful or do you feel powerful? Do you feel scared or do you feel neutral? Have you ever had a moment where you have listened, read, watched some form of true crime content and thought to yourself, that isn't that bad? Or thought, ooh, I should be responding to this more intensely than I am. This might be a sign that you need to take a step back.
If your morbid curiosity leads to empowerment, understanding, even, I guess, respect for advocacy, that's one thing. But if it leaves you feeling hopeless, detached, like the world is a terrifying place or like nothing could ever affect you like you are like stone, that might be a sign to step back. Start by really asking yourself why. Why are you being drawn to this story or this video? Is it curiosity? Is it fear? Is it boredom? Is it validation?
notice how you feel in your body after watching or reading something intense. Are you exhausted? Are you wired? Are you stressed? And does that actually leave you feeling good? Or is it something that you would rather avoid? Is there a way to learn about these things in a more neutralizing, perhaps safer manner? For example, would it be better to read a news article rather than listen to a podcast or read a Wikipedia page rather than to watch the documentary. I remember when Lucy Lettby trial was going on in the UK. I don't know if anyone's familiar with this, but she was a midwife, a nurse who killed a bunch of babies. I listened to the podcast about it, what they would report every single day what was happening in the trial.
And I remember being like, okay, this is not healthy. I obviously I'm drawn to this for whatever reason, but listening to two hours of episodes per day back to back of every single detail is not the smartest way for me to be learning about this. And I'm feeling very desensitized to what is going on. I'm also, I'm feeling equally desensitized as well as kind of upset and numb. And so I started just reading about it on the news. and I gave myself a little bit of a break from it. Like I wasn't allowed to read what happened to the case for a couple of weeks. And by the time I came back to it, it was done.
And I actually felt like I was happier and I was lighter afterwards. And I felt less irritated, perhaps because I wasn't sitting there hearing about some of the worst crimes ever committed at my desk constantly. Try as best as you can as well to limit passive consumption. Now, trust me, I know firsthand how hard it is to not. just want to switch off for a while and mindlessly scroll. Instagram, I get it, especially after a stressful day. But I do think it's important to seek out well-researched, respectful content, rather than just letting the algorithm feed you the most sensationalist stories.
If you see content that is that, say not interested, block the account. And honestly ask yourself, if this was my sister, if this was my parent, if this was my friend, And would I be okay with how they're being portrayed here? Because if the answer is no, don't give that person, that podcast, that TV station, that show any of your views or attention because it really does just promote that increasingly sensationalization of someone's real life trauma and tragedy for money. Like they're making money from this. They're making money from the worst thing that ever happened to someone.
I also want you to balance this heavy content with lightness. You know, try watching something funny every once in a while, even if you find it boring compared to your usual true crime. Go for a hike, call a friend, bake some cookies. Literally last week I did an episode on how to make your life more fun, which you can listen to for more ideas. But sometimes if you are a true crime lover, you don't realize the toll it's taking until you take a little step away.
And you're like, wow. this is what it's like to live in the lightness. Remember, as humans, we weren't meant to know all of these details about everyone's lives. We weren't meant to be able to pick up our phones and Google a million different cases and all the different pieces of data and all the different details. And we weren't meant to be able to be this aware of what was happening all over the world. we have evolved to exist in tribes of, you know, no more than 500 people and to know details about no more than 500 people's lives. So you have to be careful in not overwhelming your brain with so much intense and just extra stuff that it doesn't have time to even be present in your own life.
It's okay to say, I don't need to know more about this right now. It's not going to benefit anyone. I'm going to make a different choice. I'm going to tune into something else and just set boundaries with the content. Like that is a form of emotional self-care. And just remember your humanity. You know, it is actually fine to consume true crime content. I really hope that that has come through.
Like it is a natural human curiosity. It is evolutionary. It is linked to an e-for-control. It is linked to anxiety relief. It's super normal to want to know more information for information gathering and for preparedness. But desensitization is not a badge of honor. You don't need to watch so much that it doesn't impact you anymore. Feeling disturbed, feeling emotional, needing to look away, that is a sign that your empathy is intact. And you need empathy for almost everything in your life. And if you switch it off for one thing, you switch it off, you switch it off for everything. So please make sure that you keep your humanity about yourself whilst you're being entertained.
We are going to take a quick break right now, but when we return, we have some more listener questions, some more niche listener questions about this very topic, why we like true crime. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, Never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
he's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs
at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. People. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough
because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. So, as you guys know, I've been doing this new section of the podcast where I ask you guys are listeners to send in your listener questions. Sometimes topics are just so broad and deep and nuance that I can't answer everything in the main body. of the episode. So this just gives you guys an opportunity that if you have more specific questions or dilemmas regarding yourself, you can ask them and get answers in the episode rather than having to wait
till afterwards. So this first question I thought was an amazing way to start. Why do I continue to consume true crime content even though I know it's going to give me anxiety? So this is kind of interesting. It's different to everything else that we've discussed. Everything else we've discussed in this episode has been like, it doesn't make me anxious. It actually provides me with anxiety, relief. I feel excited rather than anxious. But this is someone who's saying, I'm drawn back to this content, even though I know it makes me feel bad. I think what's probably happening is that you are searching for mastery and you are searching for control. Anxiety is an emotion that we are endlessly trying to manage. And so when we encounter situations where it's triggered,
and we can't manage it, that actually contains a lot of fear for us. And some people choose to avoid those situations. So if you're scared of flying, really what you're scared of is the anxiety that associates flying and so you avoid the trigger, which is the plane. If you're scared of dogs, really you're not scared of dogs. You're scared of your anxiety around dogs. And so you avoid pets and you avoid animals. You seem to be going in the opposite direction.
You know you feel anxious, but you're running towards it, probably because your brain is saying, okay, like, we can't let this control us. We need to continue exposing ourselves in order to feel like we can do something about this in order to not feel beholden to our fear. It also seems like you are still trying to gain information. So your brain is kind of being pulled in two directions or your mind is being pulled in two directions. We don't like this content.
It makes me feel bad. But also, there seems to be something necessary in listening to it. it. There seems to be some kind of crucial information, so I can't look away. I need you to listen to your body and understand that it is giving you all of the signs that this is maybe just not the right kind of content for you. If you still have that morbid fascination, see if you can consume morbid content in from one of those other categories. So see if you still get that same kind of entertainment or value from supernatural things, from dangerous animals, from medical TV shows rather than true crime, it might be that you still have this morbid need, but
gory interpersonal violence is just not for you. And if you find that none of them are, it's okay to just say, hey, I'm sensitive to this stuff and just not engage with it. Like, that's not a bad thing. You really aren't missing out all that much. If you're still reading the news, if you're still got your ear to the ground, if you're still listening out, and if you still maintain good personal safety, I don't think true crime content really actually helps all that much to just see if there's another way that you can perhaps gain that mastery over your anxiety. The second question,
why does watching murderers kill not make me feel scared when I'm alone? Am I a psycho? No, it's just that it's not really happening to you. So it's actually a good thing that you can feel. safe and that you can distinguish between something that has happened to someone else, something that is perhaps fictional and something that is real. It does not make you a psycho. It actually means that you have a very stable hold over your reality. It means that you are not letting things that you see on screen influence your personal life too much. It's definitely not a bad
thing, you are definitely not a psycho. I would say if you turn around and said, well, then I want to go and murder people and I don't feel weird about it, that would make you a psycho. But you're not actually directly hurting someone or directly seeing someone be hurt. So I actually think it goes to show that your brain has a really good grasp on the difference between reality and fiction or your reality and someone else's reality. Our third question for the day, do you think there's a link between loving true crime and Freud's theory of Thanatos. Thanatos is one of those words that I've only ever seen written down. I actually don't know how it's pronounced.
So if I am butchering it, please let me know. But yes, absolutely. I'll explain what this concept means if you haven't heard of it before. Thanatos is basically our death drive. So Freud really believe that within us there are these two drives. There's the drive towards life, Eros, the drive towards survival, love, connection, creativity, passion, and then this drive towards aggression, destruction, chaos, and ultimately death. And he really believed that human behavior is shaped by a tension between these two forces.
And when you are in a good place, they balance each other out. You have an equal appreciation for both. When you think about the obsession many people have with true crime, though, and the way we consume stories of murder, violence, betrayal. You can actually see that maybe this fascination taps into our thanatos. We are being exposed to aggression, destruction, and ultimately death from a safe distance. And as a result, we're kind of vicariously dancing with this destruction that Freud says we're actually drawn to without having to experience it. We are like submerging ourselves in the representations of violence without feeling it. And so it might even give us symbolically a sense of control over our death drive as well.
Like, here I am. I am standing like ankle deep in horror and gore and some of the worst things that happen to people. And I'm not afraid. And that makes me feel strong and that makes me feel powerful. That said, I would say a lot of modern psychologists might push back and argue that it's more about curiosity. It's more about empathy. It's more about preparedness and problem solving. You know, we are drawn to understand the why behind horrific things because, you know,
it allows us to understand people better and to really explore moral boundaries. It's not because we ultimately want that to happen to us, which is what Freud would actually suggest. But love that question. Finally, why can I read watch slash listen to podcast about certain crimes but not others? I don't know. What a fascinating question. I would go so far as to say that probably the crimes you can't consume content about feel,
perhaps too close to home. And maybe there's a sense, a greater sense that they might actually happen to you. You know, murder is not actually that common as much as it dominates true crime content and the news. It's not actually that common. Whereas when we listen to stories or, you know, whatever it is about, sexual-based crimes or domestic crimes, there is this sense of like, that could maybe happen to me. The rates of that are a lot higher. Or maybe you know someone who that has happened to.
And it's that personal connection with it that makes it so difficult for you to engage with it in any way other than from a place of fear and danger. So I think that's probably what it is. you know, if you suddenly had a close friend who tragically died because of a murder murder case or something like that, you might find that actually you couldn't consume it anymore. So maybe it is that the only way you can is if you haven't personally been touched by it. But I want to see some research on that. I really, I want to do some more digging on an answer for you. But I think that is actually all that we have time for today. If you have
made it this far, drop a little emoji down below. showing me what you think of this topic it might be a devil face a scared face a knife whatever emoji best represents the true crime theme of the day i hope that i handled this tactfully i hope that you felt empathy coming through here i think talking about true crime is not something that we can take upon ourselves lightly it is it's real and it's happened to people and we have to remember that at the end of the day. Even if the podcast has a cool cover, even if the host is really fun and spunky,
like at the end of the day, that is still a real victim. And we want to make sure that we are treating that with respect. Remember, if it was you, if it was someone you loved, would you want this person to talk about them that way? And there are so many podcasts and shows who do it so, so well. So let's give them our attention.
Let's give them our money, I guess in our time rather than the shows that don't. But thank you for listening. If you've made it this far, make sure you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Let me know what you thought about this episode. You can DM me over there.
Let me know if you have anything else you want to add. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. I had so much fun exploring this with you today, and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me 84 was big to me
I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense Of how we survived it With our friends
Fellow Comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s 84 was a wild I mean It was a wild year
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcast Or wherever you get your podcast or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones.
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.